Bon, voici ce qu'on a déjà parcouru dans notre cours.
On a commencé par la considération de la relation entre les ministères des diacres et celles des anciens.
La naissance du diaconat, des précourseurs des diacres,
c'était avec le but de libérer du temps pour que les anciens ou les apôtres ne soient pas gênés
dans leur tâche principale, consécration à la prière et à l'enseignement de la parole des dieux.
Donc, c'est pour dire que nous n'allons jamais apprendre à chérir les ministères des diacres
si nous ne chérissons pas les bénéfices qu'apportent les anciens.
Et les convictions qui vont mener les diacres à bien exercer leurs fonctions et leurs rôles,
c'est aussi proportionnel à la manière dont ils chérissent les temps qui sont en train de libérer
pour que toute l'Église soit bien nourrie spirituellement.
Donc, c'est un rôle très spirituel car son objectif, c'est de catalyser,
c'est de promouvoir, d'augmenter la potence du ministère pastoral.
Ensuite, on a considéré plusieurs conceptions fausses ou incomplètes du rôle des diacres.
Il y a parfois des diacres qui ont des rôles confondus avec les anciens.
Il y a parfois des personnes qui ne sont pas appelées,
mais à cause de leur qualification ou capacité pour régler les problèmes,
ils finissent pour recevoir les titres.
Donc, il y a plusieurs conceptions différentes.
Donc, on a essayé de déconstruire un peu nos préconceptions
afin d'arriver à la compréhension biblique.
Donc, pour revenir à Acte VI, pour commencer à reconstruire la compréhension biblique,
Acte VI, c'est comme si on était en train de respirer l'atmosphère de la naissance des diacres,
même si la définition de l'office et les qualifications n'ont pas encore été de manière formelle,
rédigée, arrêtée, comme on va retrouver en 1er Timothée, dans les lettres pastorales.
Mais c'est intéressant de remarquer l'aspect organique de la naissance des diacres,
de respirer cette ambiance.
Et on a appris, en fait, que ces hommes qui ont été choisis pour régler les problèmes
qui sont apparus en Acte VI, ils sont un peu les modèles archétypes,
si on peut dire comme ça, des diacres pour nous.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer que, quelque part,
c'est que nous retrouvons en 1er Timothée III de manière plus développée,
de manière plus complète,
se retrouvent de manière radicale, comme dans une sémence ici,
un brionnaire en Acte VI.
Et donc, nous allons revenir à ce qu'on a commencé à considérer
dans la semaine dernière.
Et c'est donc les qualifications des lettres, plutôt,
ce que les diacres doivent être.
Et là, c'est très important de nous rappeler
de l'importance de l'ordre biblique.
La Bible ne parle pas beaucoup sur ce que les diacres doivent faire.
Il y a beaucoup de flexibilité,
car il y a plusieurs services différents
qui existent aujourd'hui en termes de possibilités,
qui n'existaient pas encore dans l'époque biblique.
Mais la réalité, c'est qu'il est beaucoup plus important
que les fers, c'est de définir l'être des diacres,
les qualifications des diacres,
de ce qu'ils sont,
avant de considérer les capacitations ou les capacités
par rapport à ce qu'ils peuvent faire.
Et c'est important de nous rappeler de ça,
car plusieurs églises sont plutôt menées
par les nécessités urgentes,
par des idées créatives,
des départements qu'ils voulaient développer,
des activités qu'ils voulaient faire.
Et ça rend les choses beaucoup plus simples ou faciles
si nous avons des personnes qui peuvent être là pour tout faire.
Et parfois, nous pensons plutôt à la capacité de personnes,
à l'aspect pragmatique,
au lieu de penser à l'être.
Par contre, la Bible, elle est très emphatique,
elle met beaucoup d'emphase
sur l'importance d'être avant de les faire.
En fait, dans la conception biblique,
nous n'exprimons à l'extérieur,
nous ne faisons qu'il y ait des choses,
car nous sommes plutôt en train de manifester extérieurement
par nos actions, par notre comportement,
par nos services, ce qui nous sommes.
Et c'est intéressant,
nous allons considérer l'importance
d'une période des tests probatoires
dans les services des plus possibles candidats,
car c'est impossible
qu'on dévoile plus tôt ou plus tard par nos actions
ce qui nous sommes,
et ce qui parfois,
on a été plus ou moins capables de cacher.
Mais la réalité, c'est que nous devons d'abord
et avant tout cibler l'être.
Donc, on doit rappeler par là
que nous sommes devant un office qui est sacré,
ce sont les deux offices séparés des dieux,
des activités plusieurs
qu'on pourrait avoir à l'Église,
mais il y a les deux offices séparés
de manière particulière pour exercer cet office,
dont les qualifications sont très similaires
pour les anciens et pour les diacres.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer
que nous devons nous rappeler avant tout
qu'il s'agit des dons des dieux à l'Église.
Et si ces personnes-là ont été appelées par Dieu
pour être diacres ou anciens,
ces personnes, elles sont déjà les produits
d'une œuvre surnaturelle des dieux et particulière.
Et ça, c'est très important.
Et donc, la première chose qu'on a considérée,
en revêtant au texte, c'est de nous rappeler
que nous sommes devant des conditions solennelles,
universelles et non négociables.
Universelles, pourquoi ?
Car lorsqu'on arrive au verset 14 à 16,
l'apôtre Paul, après avoir donné les instructions
par rapport aux qualifications des diacres,
il va dire, j'ai écrit ces choses
avec l'espérance d'aller bientôt vers toi,
mais afin que tu saches si j'étarde,
et là c'est intéressant,
comment il faut se conduire.
Et là, il n'est plus en train de parler
qu'à Timothée, il est en train de parler
de manière absolue, perpétuelle,
pour toujours.
Dieu nous a laissé des critères clairs
de comment il faut toujours
se porter dans l'Église,
comment il faut conduire l'Église.
Et donc, c'est-à-dire que
quand on va identifier les critères bibliques
pour identifier,
en appeler pour être diacre,
nous ne pouvons pas négliger
ces principes qui sont,
pour tous les temps,
et sont universels.
Ensuite, on a considéré
qu'il s'agit des conditions solennelles.
C'est intéressant.
À partir du moment où il dit
dans la maison des dieux,
c'est conduire dans la maison des dieux,
c'est pour prendre conscience
que nous sommes responsables,
rédévables à Dieu.
On va rendre compte à Dieu
de la manière dont on gère
ou on joue avec son Église.
Car nous sommes des entendants,
nous, tous les chrétiens,
l'Église,
qui va reconnaître les dons des dieux
et les diacres.
Donc, comment il faut se conduire ?
C'est rapport à la notion
des qualifications d'anciens des diacres.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer,
c'est en phase
que l'apôtre Paul est en train de faire
sur la maison des dieux.
Il fait appel à la conscience
de Timothée
pour qu'il se rappelle toujours
qu'il n'est pas en train
de jouer avec sa propre maison.
Voilà pourquoi c'est toujours gênant
quand les pasteurs,
au lieu de faire ses fonctions
pendant les cultes,
ils commencent à saluer les gens.
Ils commencent parfois
à saluer même des invités
jusqu'à il s'agit d'une personne célèbre
ou d'une personne
qui est liée à la politique, etc.
Comme s'il était à sa maison.
Et là, c'est intéressant de remarquer
dans la parole des dieux.
Nous sommes dans la maison des dieux
et nous n'avons pas beaucoup de temps
qui peut nous rester
si nous voulons faire
toutes les choses
que Dieu veut qu'on fasse
et qui sont prioritaires.
Et donc,
la maison des dieux
et ils sont solennels,
car ensuite,
il va dire
la maison des dieux
qui a la colonne
et l'appui de la vérité
et sans contredit,
les mystères de la piété est grand,
c'est lui qui a été manifesté en chair,
justifié par l'esprit,
vu des anges prêchés aux gentils,
crus dans les mondes,
élevés dans la gloire.
Donc, c'est pour que Timothée
garde toujours frais
ce que Christ a dû vivre,
ce que Christ a dû faire
et le fait qu'aujourd'hui,
il est à sa place
des suprêmes gloires
qui est toujours liée
à la notion d'autorité
et nous sommes rédévables
au Seigneur du Seigneur
qui va revenir
par rapport à la manière
dont on gère son Église.
Donc, c'est solennel,
c'est-à-dire,
nous ne pouvons pas
considérer
que les critères,
et c'est le troisième aspect,
ce sont des conditions
non négociables,
c'est-à-dire,
on ne peut pas,
je me rappelle
quand j'ai dû me présenter
à l'armée
pour voir
si j'allais servir ou non,
mais c'était intéressant
car à cause de mon auteur,
on m'a dit
que je pourrais considérer
faire les parachutes
comme si c'était
un privilège intéressant.
Et ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que quand on considère
les critères d'une armée,
une personne
qui n'avait pas
la hauteur exacte définie
en général
ne pourra pas,
en fait,
dire
qu'il était presque là,
qu'il avait 1,82 m
et c'était 1,83 m.
Et ça ne va pas passer.
Les suprêmes générales
qu'il a laissées,
les coordonnées très claires
et ce sont ces qualifications
qu'il faut avoir,
rien ne manquer ça.
Et donc là,
on voit,
les diacres doivent être.
OK ?
Verset 8 et verset 11,
les diacres doivent être,
à nouveau.
Donc,
ce sont des choses
qui ne sont pas des conseils,
des possibilités,
ce n'est pas,
il vaut mieux qu'ils soient,
c'est,
ils doivent l'être.
OK ?
Et ensuite,
donc on a considéré
conditions universelles,
solennelles,
non négociables
et on a considéré
que ces qualifications,
OK,
sont des qualifications
spirituelles.
Les offices ecclésiales,
à nouveau,
sont un don des dieux
à l'Église
et donc ces hommes
sont l'objet
d'une agence
surnaturelle
du Saint-Esprit
qui les a rendus
capables,
qui les a
purifiés,
quelque part,
par une espèce
de crainte
au-dessus de la moyenne,
par une espèce
de sens
de rédivabilité,
un sens
de responsabilité.
Vous voyez,
à cause de cette grâce,
à cause de cette conscience
davantage éveillée,
à cause de la grâce
que Dieu
aucun mérite à eux,
ils ont été qualifiés,
ils ont été
rendus capables,
ils ont été rendus
propres
par Dieu lui-même,
par la mesure
des grâces
qu'il a employées
sur ces personnes
pour qu'ils puissent
exercer
ces fonctions.
Et donc,
nous ne pouvons jamais
mépriser les dons
qui Dieu a donnés
à l'Église
et nous ne pouvons
jamais
employer
pour certains offices
des personnes
qui Dieu
ne nous a pas donnés
pour les faire.
C'est clair pour vous ?
Et donc,
c'est un don,
un produit
surnaturel
et donc,
aucune force humaine
ne peut produire
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que quand on considère
les précourseurs
qui sont les modèles
pour nous,
les critères sont
choisissez parmi vous
cet homme
qui l'en rende
un bon témoignage,
c'est-à-dire
ils ont un comportement,
une constance,
un crédit
des piétés
évidentes
au sein de la communauté,
qu'il soit
plein du Saint-Esprit
et des sagesses,
donc c'est la sagesse
qui est issue
du Saint-Esprit,
mais qu'il soit
plein du Saint-Esprit
et qu'ils nous chargeront
de cet emploi.
Donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer en fait
que toutes les qualifications
qu'on va considérer
en 1 Timothée 3
sont des qualifications
spirituelles.
OK ?
C'est aucun être humain,
aucune force
ne peut produire
ces choses
de manière légitime.
Mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que si ces choses
sont là,
c'est impossible aussi
que cette personne
s'enorgueillisse
car la même personne
qui a été qualifiée
pour servir
à cause d'une bonne réputation
et d'être remplie
de Saint-Esprit,
le Saint-Esprit
est l'esprit
d'humiliation,
d'humilité
et cette personne
sera toujours consciente
du fait qu'elle est pécheresse.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de ne jamais séparer
l'action
ou la conception
des Saint-Esprit,
soyez avec moi,
la conception des Saint-Esprit
qui est double toujours,
c'est des rendre propres
pour séparer,
pour un usage particulier.
Donc,
il y a toujours la notion
d'un caractère apte
à exercer
un office sacré
couplé
à une espèce
de capacitation
qui rend apte
à l'usage.
Donc,
c'est la notion
des propriétés
et la notion
des fonctions.
C'est un instrument
qui doit être
net.
C'est un vase
qui doit être
purifié
à l'intérieur.
C'est très intéressant.
Donc,
dans la Bible,
quand Dieu
veut faire usage
de certains instruments,
il va les purifier,
il va les nettoyer,
il ne va pas
servir
un verre d'eau
à un invité
si le verre
est sale.
Et donc,
c'est impossible
de concilier
impropriété,
on dit ça en français,
d'être impropre
avec les services
pour les seigneurs.
Les manques
de pureté
vont invalider,
vont disqualifier
pour l'usage
dans la maison
des dieux.
C'est clair ?
Et donc,
acte 6,
elle a les mêmes
qualifications,
un peu plus condensées,
radicales,
qu'est premier
Timothée 3.
Mais si jamais
nous devrions,
et là,
c'est vraiment
un défi très grand,
car quand on pense,
par exemple,
les fruits du Saint-Esprit,
parfois on a l'impression
que nous pouvons avoir
quelques-uns,
mais pas quelques autres.
La réalité,
c'est que tous les chrétiens
doivent présenter
les fruits du Saint-Esprit.
Et les fruits du Saint-Esprit,
c'est comme une clémentine.
Il est plutôt
un seul fruit,
mais avec plusieurs facettes,
plusieurs gommes ?
Comment on dit
en français ?
Cartier,
ok.
Ok.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que nous devons
avoir tous,
même si parfois
l'un
est plus fort
que l'autre,
la réalité,
c'est que toutes
les facettes
doivent être présentes
dans la vie du chrétien,
et toute qualification
pour diacre
ou pour ancien
doivent être présentes.
il ne faut pas avoir
quatre ou cinq,
mais pas les six ou sept.
La réalité,
c'est que tous,
tous ces éléments
doivent être là
chez cette personne.
Et donc,
dans un certain sens,
ils sont inséparables.
Vous allez remarquer
que les choses
vont s'achévaucher
à plusieurs reprises,
mais la réalité,
c'est que nous pouvons
porter une division
en termes de didactique
où nous avons proposé
la semaine dernière
entre quelques qualifications
qu'on va appeler plutôt
morales ou personnelles,
plutôt internes,
et quelques qualifications
qui sont plutôt
relationnelles,
plus liées à l'exercice
de la fonction
et qui s'y voient
de manière plus relationnelle
à l'extérieur.
Donc,
on a déjà traversé
les quatre qualifications
personnelles
qui montrent
un caractère spirituel.
OK ?
Quelles sont
les quatre qualifications
personnelles ?
Donc,
la première,
et en fait,
cette première,
c'est comme si on était
devant les fruits complets.
C'est
toutes les autres qualifications
seront issues
et seront couvertes
par cette conception.
C'est les termes bibliques
pour désigner la dignité.
OK ?
Donc,
il faut qu'ils soient
dignes.
OK ?
Les diacres,
c'est 8,
aussi doivent être dignes.
Et cette conception biblique
de dignité,
elle est une conception
très profonde
et très large.
C'est comme si
on était devant
la caractéristique
la plus évidente.
Donc,
je vais garder
les proportions
en filet inférieur,
mais quand on pense
à la conception biblique
de la gloire des dieux,
qu'est-ce qu'on pense
quand on pense
à la gloire des dieux ?
On pense dans un éclat
des bris,
des lumières.
Et la réalité,
c'est que pour décrire
la gloire des dieux,
certaines personnes vont dire
c'est la somme
de toutes ses vertus.
C'est comme si
on avait considéré
et adoré Dieu
par la contemplation
de chacune
de ses vertus,
de ses attributs,
donc des dieux
qui sont infiniment sages.
On va rendre gloire
à Dieu par sa sagesse.
Les dieux qui sont amours,
qui ont un amour
infini et inconditionnel.
On va glorifier Dieu
par son amour.
C'est les dieux
qui sont patients
ou les dieux
qui sont tout-puissants
et en contemplant
chacune des vertus
des dieux
qui nous conduisent
à adorer,
nous pouvons considérer
de manière
multifacétaire
la gloire des dieux.
Mais la réalité,
c'est que les personnes
qui ont eu
cette expérience directe
avec la contemplation
de la gloire des dieux,
c'est comme si
on voyait
l'ensemble des dieux
en rayonnant
dans la beauté
de sa sainteté.
Et c'est cette gloire
des dieux
qui va se manifester.
Et c'est quelque part
un terme,
une conception biblique
qui nous parle
d'une espèce
de majesté,
d'honneur,
de dignité
et de beauté
qui ressort
d'une personne
qui vit
ses niveaux
des piétés,
par exemple.
Et donc,
c'est une personne
en qui nous
retrouvons
la beauté
du Christ,
qui est une personne
similaire à Christ,
mais qui est
digne,
elle est digne
des respects,
d'honneur,
elle est digne
d'admiration,
elle mène
une vie digne.
Les diacres
aussi doivent être
dignes.
Ils doivent être
pas parfaits,
bien sûr,
mais humbles,
répandants,
mais exemplaires
pour tous les troupeaux.
Donc,
quelques aspects
dont cette dignité
s'affiche.
D'abord,
les diacres,
ils sont dignes
ou ils inspirent
la dignité
ou le respect
car ils cherchent
à se présenter
à Christ
pour lui servir
en toute dignité.
Donc,
l'emphase
que j'ai mise
sur la notion
d'être propre,
c'est qu'ils préservent,
la seule chose
qu'ils peuvent préserver
un diacre
dans cette dignité
n'est pas
l'apparence
que les hommes
auront de lui.
Ce qui lui motive
à garder
une réputation digne
n'est pas,
en fait,
comment les personnes
vont me voir.
C'est la conscience
pleine
et profonde
qu'ils sont
avant tout
dans une tâche
dont les privilèges
sont de servir
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
C'est le plus proche
qu'on puisse imaginer,
c'est la conception
biblique des anges.
Les anges,
avec tous les respects
et solennels,
mais Lloyd-Jones,
il va illustrer
comme s'il s'agissait
de ces chiants,
des gardes
dont le plaisir principal
c'est d'obéir
à la direction
du maître.
Ils sont toujours là
devant la face
des dieux
avec les privilèges
d'adorer Dieu constamment,
de glorifier Dieu
par sa dignité,
mais comme nous ne pouvons
rien faire
ni pour augmenter
la gloire de Dieu
ni pour être digne
dans sa présence,
la seule chose
que nous pouvons faire
c'est de servir.
Et donc,
c'est comme si les anges
avaient fait
leur plus grand plaisir
c'est d'attendre
une ordonnance
pour faire les services
les plus humbles
possible.
Car ce qui fait
du travail des diacres
un travail digne
n'est pas forcément
la tâche en soi,
mais c'est celui
à qui nous servons.
Et donc,
son plus grand plaisir
c'est de s'éporter
de manière digne
devant Dieu
afin que Dieu
ait le plaisir
de les commissionner
à servir
dans une tâche.
Vous comprenez
la relation ?
C'est de considérer
que je dois
me présenter
de la manière
la plus pure
possible
devant Dieu
pour que je sois
plus efficace,
pour que j'ai
un osage
plus efficace
dans les mondes de Dieu,
pour que Dieu
ait les plaisirs
à me commissionner.
C'est ça qui préserve
la dignité
d'un diacre.
Ensuite,
il voit la dignité
dans les services
les plus humbles
car ces services
sont rendus à Christ.
Donc,
il n'est pas préoccupé
à nouveau
comment les hommes
vont voir la manière
dont on fait les choses
ou c'est qu'on va faire
mais nous faisons
toutes ces choses
avec l'essence
des dignités
pour plus simple
que ce soit
car nous sommes en train
de gérer
la maison des dieux.
C'est la maison des dieux.
Vous imaginez
les privilèges
qui est de nettoyer
la maison des dieux.
OK ?
Et donc,
c'est là
où les diacres
ont cette compréhension
que le Seigneur Jésus
est à du plaisir
dans les mondes de service.
Il sert à Christ
et non les autres.
Donc,
tout service est digne
car il sert le Christ.
il est digne.
Il voit aussi la dignité
dans toutes les implications
spirituelles
du service
qu'ils sont en train
de rendre à Christ.
Donc,
si la maison des dieux,
attention,
est la colonne
et l'appui de la vérité,
si ce qui se passe ici
sont les enjeux éternels
pour les saluts des âmes,
pour faire avancer
les rômes des dieux,
pour plus simple
qu'il soit un service
que je puisse rendre
au sein de l'église,
je vois toujours
l'implication spirituelle
de ça.
Peut-être que les personnes
ne voient pas
la liaison
de manière très directe,
mais si je suis en train
de libérer du temps
pour que les anciens
étudient plus,
prient plus,
enseignent plus,
et si je suis en train
de faciliter l'unité
de l'église
pour qu'on puisse porter
plus de fruits,
je vais embrasser
n'importe quelle opportunité
de service
car il y aura toujours
des implications spirituelles
de l'église.
très importante,
je serai un catalyseur
de l'église.
Il va aussi la dignité
dans la maison
et dans les peuples
des dieux
en tout service rendu.
Donc ça,
c'est un point vraiment
très important
car il ne regarde pas
les enfants des dieux
par, on va dire,
la laideur,
la mocheté
qui nous présentons
encore
comme travaux,
comme encore
en construction,
en travaux.
Ça, c'est la réalité
de nous tous.
Et si nous sommes motivés
par les mérites,
nous ne serons pas
très motivés
à servir.
Si nous sommes motivés
par les retours
que les personnes
vont faire,
les observations
qu'elles vont faire,
par les respects,
pour même la gratitude
de la reconnaissance,
c'est légitime
que toutes les personnes
soient reconnaissantes
et qu'elles sachent
chérir
ce qu'elles font
les diacres.
Mais elles ne sont pas
dans la dépendance
de ces choses.
Elles ont la compréhension
qu'elles sont en train
de traiter
la maison des dieux
et donc ils font
pour Dieu
et les peuples des dieux.
C'est la prunelle
des yeux du Christ.
Nous sommes l'épouse
du Christ.
Et donc,
avec toute dignité,
les diacres portent
les services
les plus humbles
à n'importe qui
et particulièrement
à tous les chrétiens,
sachant que malgré
les mérites
que ces chrétiens
puissent avoir,
parfois on va être là
en train de nettoyer
la maison des dieux
et on va se dire
mais pourquoi
ces frères
ou cette sœur
n'ont jamais
nettoyé
une seule tâche.
Pourquoi ?
Ils ont l'impression
qu'ils se sentent
aussi importants
qu'ils ne veulent
même pas aider.
Comment ils se sentent
cette paix en fait
de partir aussitôt
sans porter une aide
lorsqu'il y a plusieurs
qui arrivent
plus tôt que moi
et qui sont là
pour ranger
la maison des dieux
mais les diacres
ne sont pas en train
de réfléchir à ces choses.
Ils sont en train
de réfléchir
au fait
que ok,
c'est pour leur bien,
c'est pour leur motivation,
c'est pour leur développement
dans la foi
et donc les diacres
ils les font
en prenant en considération
la dignité
du peuple des dieux
et de la maison des dieux.
Et voilà pourquoi
en fait à la fin
ils préservent
cette dignité
devant les personnes
car ils font
toutes les choses
pour la dignité
et la gloire
du Christ.
Ils font toutes les choses
avec excellence.
C'est là
où on doit
chercher les motivations
pour faire les choses
avec excellence.
donc en participant
à cette retraite
de HeartCry
récemment
on a dû lire
en fait
tous les manuels
qu'ils ont
pour les missionnaires
et j'ai trouvé
très intéressant
en fait
car même si aujourd'hui
HeartCry
est devenue
une agence missionnaire
qui a reçu
beaucoup
des contributions
financières
ils sont très responsables
dans la manière
dont ils vont gérer
leur argent
et une des choses
qui a été écrite
dans l'ère manuelle
c'est qu'ils traitent
chaque centime
comme l'offre
de la pauvre veuve
qui a été faite.
Et donc
lorsqu'on va gérer
par exemple
ces matériaux
qui sont très
technologiques
et fragiles
on fait beaucoup
d'efforts
pour ranger
de la meilleure
manière possible
pourquoi ?
Car on sait
que peut-être
certains plus aidés
dans la communauté
ont contribué
à cet achat
mais aussi
les plus démunis
ceux qui traversent
des moments faibles
difficiles
et donc on va gérer
tout dans la maison
des dieux
en prenant en considération
l'honneur
et la dignité
de chaque effort
qui est fait
par la communauté.
Donc voilà
comment cette personne
s'épargne de manière digne
et fait les choses
avec excellence.
Donc l'excellence
avec laquelle
on sert les seigneurs
elle est proportionnelle
à la conception
qu'on a
de la dignité
des dieux
à qui nous servons
et au sens
des privilèges
qu'on a
de les servir.
Elle est aussi proportionnelle
au sens
d'intendance
et de redévabilité
car même si personne
est en train de voir
comment je suis en train
de gérer les choses
si je suis en train
de mal gérer les choses
irresponsablement
là je dois me rappeler
que Dieu
est en train de les voir
et je suis redévable
à lui
par rapport à ça.
Amen ?
Je dois avancer
un peu plus vite.
Il est aussi
exemple
des duplicités
on a beaucoup parlé
sur ça
la semaine dernière.
Bon
c'est d'avoir
un double langage
c'est de dire
une chose
et faire autre
c'est de dire
une chose
à une personne
autre chose
à autre personne
c'est d'écouter
plus qu'on ait des vrais
ou de parler
plus qu'il est nécessaire
et le rôle
de diac
il est très important
car comme
ils vont prendre soin
des gens
des personnes
ils doivent aussi
savoir garder
les informations
car même les personnes
qui ont besoin
d'être aidées
parfois elles sont
timides
elles ne veulent pas
que ces choses
soient
connues
mais c'est surtout
l'indice
d'un cœur
double
qui vit
d'apparence
qui cherche
à maintenir
une apparence
et qui parfois
cherche même
à résoudre
des solutions
par un manque
d'honnêteté
de transparence
de vérité
nous ne devrions
même pas
donner l'impression
d'aller vers un chemin
et prendre un autre
même si c'est pour
régler un problème
nous sommes
les peuples
de la vérité
du cœur
transparent
d'une seule volonté
une seule envie
et donc nous
nous ne pouvons pas
vivre d'apparence
car l'apparence
mène à la partialité
et donc c'est intéressant
car nous devons dire
la vérité
avec amour
mais nous ne devons pas
en fait
chercher
n'avoir jamais
confronté
les personnes
avec la peur
en fait
que les choses
deviennent compliquées
nous devons
parler la vérité
avec amour
sans être
trop grossier
dans la manière
dont on parle
mais nous ne devons
pas non plus
tourner trop
autour du pot
il y a certaines
personnes entre nous
qui sont
naturellement
plus douées
avec un langage
plus paisible
plus ferme
et d'autres non
et la réalité
c'est que
des fois
j'ai déjà vécu
une expérience
où un d'entre nous
un groupe de pasteurs
à chaque fois
qu'il allait participer
à quelque chose
il allait porter
par exemple
une proposition
d'amélioration
ou une correction
mais il faisait
toujours un préamble
d'éloge
énorme
à chaque fois
j'ai tellement apprécié
ceci ou cela
etc
c'est toujours bien
d'équilibrer les choses
que je puisse
encourager beaucoup
avant de corriger
mais des fois
en fait
il faut qu'on soit
tout simplement
transparent
qu'on puisse
gagner du temps
dire les choses
avec amour
mais avec fermeté
sans chercher
toujours
que l'apparence
du gars
toujours
très agréable
soit là
on n'est pas
préoccupé
l'image
qu'on vise à former
avec les personnes
pour plus que
l'image
qu'on doit former
chez les personnes
soit l'image
d'un homme pieux
et un homme pieux
présentera l'image
d'un homme pieux
il n'est pas
préoccupé
comment je me présente
il est préoccupé
à comment m'approfondir
dans ma foi
comment me remplir
de son esprit
et naturellement
j'essaierai
ce que je suis
vous comprenez
et Lloyd Jones
il racontait une fois
un homme qui
possiblement était
un diacre d'une église
il est allé prêcher
dans une autre ville
et les messieurs
qu'il a reçus
c'était un messieurs
qui était possiblement
un diacre
qui allait chercher
la gare
et à chaque fois
il disait
qui suis moi
pour pouvoir
vous recevoir
un homme de Dieu
un missionnaire
mais je ne suis rien
mais c'est un plaisir
pour moi
j'ouvre la porte
je fais ceci
cela
et Lloyd Jones
dans son cœur
il a dit
quand il était
en train d'illustrer
ses points
il a dit
c'était clairement
un homme
qui était tellement
intéressé
à manifester
son humilité
qui c'était
comme s'il était
orgueilleux
de son humilité
et la réalité
c'est que parfois
on fait trop d'efforts
en fait
pour manifester
de manière explicite
évidente
et de manière exagérée
quelques vertus chrétiennes
et ça ressort
comme un étant
pas légitime
des choses forcées
et donc nous devons
l'être
mais nous ne devons
jamais essayer
de les présenter
de manière artificielle
et donc c'est naturel
de considérer
cette importance
donc les diacres
ils sont là
des personnes qualifiées
à contrôler
leur langue
et faire
que leur langue
soit un instrument
naturel
d'expression
de leur piété
de leur dignité
ok
ils sont aussi
exemples
de l'excès du vent
1 Timothée 3.8
les diacres aussi
doivent être dignes
éloignés
de la duplicité
et des excès
du vent
donc là
c'est intéressant
nous devons contrôler
la langue
mais nous devons
aussi contrôler
l'estomac
la langue
est un véhicule
d'expression
de notre spiritualité
aussi comme
le corps
est une expression
ou un véhicule
d'expression
de notre spiritualité
nous devons
résister
aux tentations
de la langue
aussi
qui est la tentation
de l'appétit
et les principes
de base ici
c'est notamment
la maîtrise
de soi
donc les saints
esprits
c'est un saint
esprit
qui nous rend
capables
de mener
une vie
gouvernée
surtout par la raison
qui est par les instants
ou par
les appétits
donc c'est intéressant
la langue
a été manifestée
comme un premier lieu
donc très important
mais aussi
la notion
du vent
c'est intéressant
car ici
c'est un appel
non seulement
à la maîtrise
des soirs
comme l'apôtre Paul
va présenter
d'autre part
et qui vont toucher
l'ensemble du rapport
envers les nourritures
et les exagérations
mais c'est aussi
des plaisirs
démodérés
envers
une espèce
de joie
qui devrait être
plutôt retrouvée
ou remplacée
par la joie
dans le Saint-Esprit
car
des fois
en fait
si
on se demande
pourquoi
on est en train
de nous déverser
envers ce plaisir
la réponse
parfois
c'est
à cause
d'une espèce
d'anxiété
parfois
d'une espèce
de consolation
la vie
elle est tellement
difficile
je ne peux
aujourd'hui
ni faire
ceci
ni cela
au moins
je vais me permettre
d'avoir ce plaisir
et donc la réalité
c'est que même là
on est en train
de remplacer
une joie supérieure
qu'on pourrait retrouver
toujours
dans le Saint-Esprit
remplissez-vous
avec le Saint-Esprit
au lieu de vous
inivrer
avec les vents
et pas qu'avec
les plaisirs
qu'il y a trouvé
dans la nourriture
ou dans les vents
mais aussi
la tentation
de nous consoler
ou de nous distraire
et par là
chercher à oublier
et nous enfuir
au lieu de régler
et faire face
à nos problèmes
car
lorsqu'on est devant
un problème
et les diacres
sont appelés
à faire face
aux problèmes
ils sont là
pour étendre
les feux
pour enlever
les divisions
il faut qu'ils soient
constamment
dans les meilleurs
osages
de leurs raisons
et ne pas
se laisser porter
par cette invitation
à m'aider
d'étendre un peu
par les vents
ou par quoi que ce soit
mais bon
c'est l'excès
qui est interdit
donc cette personne
n'essaiera pas
en train de s'efforcer
à résister
c'est une personne
qui n'est pas caractérisée
pour prendre son plaisir
ou sa consolation
ou sa distraction
dans les vents
ou dans la nourriture
c'est quelqu'un
qui est rempli
de son esprit
qui est à l'opposé
de la notion
de l'excès du vent
donc c'est
quelqu'un
qui doit être
toujours apte
à donner
les mieux
de son raisonnement
à sa fonction
c'est quelqu'un
circonspect
qui va pouvoir
juger les choses
avec les mieux
de son raisonnement
ok
donc exemple
de l'excès
du vent
ils sont aussi
exemple
des gants
honteux
on a un peu parlé
sur ça
et c'est très important
donc
l'excès du gant
ça parle
les gants
honteux
ça peut être
vraiment
les gants
sordides
malhonnêtes
mais ça peut être
aussi
de manière générale
dans ce moment public
c'est
une personne
qui a
les cœurs
très accrochés
au bien
temporel
et c'est surtout
aussi la possibilité
des gants
des personnes
qui prennent
l'avantage
je vous ai donné
l'exemple
des pouvoirs
à chaque fois
chercher
j'oublie
quand je me sens
lésé
par une entreprise
et je veux
prendre des indemnisations
à gauche
à droite
etc
donc des fois
c'est juste
mais il y a pas mal
des personnes
dans la génération
qui vont
toujours
l'expression
picassiette
c'est ça
ok
donc c'est plutôt
cette notion là
car
les diacres
ils seront
exposés
à des opportunités
ils seront chargés
par exemple
de gérer
quelques montants
d'argent
comme on va dans la Bible
lorsqu'on va envoyer
l'argent à une église
et tout
on peut le faire
à travers un diacre
ou même
pour un acte 6
pour résoudre
un problème
qui a dû traverser
aussi
en fait
l'achat
et donc
il sera exposé
à cette tentation
et même si
c'est pas forcément
exposé à la tentation
de l'argent
en soi-même
il peut être aussi
exposé à la tentation
tout simplement
de la place
ou la position
d'influence
de faire des amitiés
de réjouir
de l'hospitalité
et voilà
de se nourrir
des maisons et maisons
et donc par là
être rusé
et sage
on voit comment
Judas
il a un peu
joué de cette manière
et comment
il profitait
des occasions
qu'il avait
et donc là
on a considéré
en fait
comment on peut
évaluer la vie
d'une telle personne
donc on voit
comment cette personne
met en valeur
les richesses
comment il peut
se couvrir
par des images
des richesses
de manière
très superficielle
ou superflue
on voit
son emploi du temps
que c'est
peut-être légitime
ok
que ceux
qui ont bien géré
leur argent
soient plus doués
à s'occuper
d'un service
dans les diaconats
qui soient plus liés
à la gestion
des finances
mais en même temps
il faut savoir
que ce n'est pas ça
les critères primaires
et la réalité
c'est qu'il faut se demander
si par exemple
pour qu'il prospère
et qu'il arrive
à administrer
ses biens
est-ce qu'il a respecté
les principes bibliques
est-ce qu'il l'a fait
sans sacrifier sa piété
ou sa famille
je ne peux pas regarder
la fin de l'histoire
sans me demander
comment il est arrivé
et donc c'est important
de savoir
si au long du procès
il a été fidèle
dans la générosité
envers la cause
du royaume
et pas tout simplement
considérer
que comme la personne
est riche
et capable
de bien gérer
son argent
est-ce qu'il a réussi
car il était
très radant
ou est-ce qu'il a réussi
à point
qu'il devienne
très trivial
car à la fin
en fait
une personne
qui soit
qualifiée
pour être un diacre
mais qui n'est pas riche
peut-être
car il a été
très libéral
très généreux
ou même
qu'il traverse
des moments difficiles
tels que Dieu
l'a dessiné
mais cette personne
parfois
elle est plus
prédisposée
à se courir
les plus démunis
car par son expérience
il a vécu
ce que les autres
ont vécu
et elle est plus
sensible
à cette cause
et donc nous devons
savoir équilibrer
car une personne
qui traverse
des difficultés
peut-être
plus qualifiée
pour gérer
l'argent des dieux
selon la volonté
des dieux
qu'une personne
qui est très riche
et qui parfois
n'a pas fait
donc ce n'est pas
le fait d'être riche
ou le fait d'être épreuve
la réalité c'est
d'avoir cette qualification
d'intégrité
d'honnêteté
et de chérir
les principes publics
de la dignité
de travail
ok
et donc là
on a parlé
pas mal
sur ces aspects-là
et finalement
en arrivant
à quelque chose
de nouveau
quatre qualifications
relationnelles
ok
donc on a parlé
des qualifications
plutôt des caractères
et maintenant
plutôt
c'est encore
caractère spirituel
mais qui s'affiche
plutôt dans
les fonctions
et la relation
des diacres
donc la première
c'est très intéressant
c'est quelque chose
qu'on pourrait
ne pas s'attendre
de manière très évidente
de la part des diacres
mais c'est
le verset 9
nous dit
conservant
les mystères
de la foi
dans une conscience
pure
donc je vous ai dit
que
c'est possible
en fait
que la seule chose
qui puisse préserver
l'intégrité
d'un ministère
des diacres
ou même d'anciens
soit
la conscience
et la conviction
d'être appelé
à ces ministères
d'avoir été qualifié
pour ces ministères
il faut que cette personne
elle ait
l'essence
des responsabilités
la crainte
savoir qu'elle est
rédévable
devant Dieu
qu'elle va rendre compte
par rapport à la manière
dont elle sert
c'est très intéressant
car
lorsqu'il pôle
vise à préserver
son ministère
il va dire
qu'il cherche toujours
à avoir
et présenter
une conscience pure
devant Dieu
et devant les hommes
et quand il va faire
appel à Timothée
il va faire appel
à Timothée
de préserver
une conscience pure
pourquoi
car
à la fin des comptes
cette personne
il faut qu'elle soit
devant Dieu
tous les temps
il faut qu'elle sache
qu'elle est en train
de gérer la maison
des dieux
prendre soin
des prunelles
de ses yeux
les peuples des dieux
et c'est la seule chose
qu'à la fin des comptes
peut préserver
car
s'il est en train
d'exercer cette fonction
par l'apparence
par les bénéfices
par les maintiens
par un désir
d'être en évidence
aucun
ou aucune
de ces raisons
ne seront suffisantes
les jours
où les choses
peuvent devenir
difficiles
défiantes
pour qu'ils délaissent
ou les jours
où la tentation
arrive plus forte
qu'ils résistent
la seule chose
plus forte
qu'est de craindre
les hommes
c'est de craindre
Dieu
et donc quand les personnes
disent
mais comment
cet homme
a le courage
de dire ces choses
de manière aussi claire
et directe
et frontale
comment il a le courage
de toucher à ses points
et confronter
et la réponse
qu'on doit dire
c'est pas que cet homme
là est très courageux
c'est qu'il est en train
de craindre
la bonne personne
s'il craint
les hommes
il peut toujours
chercher à s'adapter
à leurs envies
leur volonté
leur goût
mais s'il craint
Dieu
toujours et avant tout
ça c'est l'homme
qui craint
la bonne personne
et voilà pourquoi
les hommes de Dieu
sont intègres
c'est pas car ils sont
les plus courageux
ce sont ceux
qui sont un peu
plus intelligents
par rapport à qui
on doit craindre
ok
on doit trembler
devant Dieu
et donc voilà
pourquoi la conscience
pure
c'est une conscience
qui est
correctement éveillée
la conscience
donc vous vous rappelez
du passage
où Paul va dire
par exemple
on sait qu'il n'existe pas
des faux dieux
etc
donc manger
c'est sans demander
il n'y a pas un problème
il y a un seul dieux
vous pouvez manger
même si c'est sacrifié
etc
mais à la fin
il va dire
mais si certains
ont encore des doutes
qu'ils ne mangent pas
car c'est lui
qui n'ont pas
des convictions correctes
et qui pêchent
contre leurs convictions
ils sont en train
de commettre
un péché
qu'est-ce qu'il peut
être en train de dire
par là
leur conscience
ne sont pas
en train de fonctionner
correctement
mais la dernière instance
des jugements
reste quand même
la conscience
et donc quel est
les challenges pour nous
c'est que nos consciences
soient instruites
par la parole de Dieu
devant la présence
de Dieu
afin que nous puissions
développer un ministère
agréable à Dieu
la seule personne
qui peut mener
un ministère intègre
c'est une personne
qui a une conscience pure
et donc faire appel
à la conscience
d'une personne
qui a la conscience
cautérisée
ça ne sert pas
à grand chose
mais si quelqu'un
est convaincu
de l'importance
de ce qu'il fait
devant Dieu
c'est très important
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
car
on sait
que nous ne pouvons
pas confondre
les rôles des diacres
avec les rôles
des anciens
nous savons
que la compétence
des diacres
est plus liée
aux services pratiques
et les compétences
des anciens
sont plus liées
et prédominamment liées
à la direction
de l'église
et l'étude
des écritures
par contre
ici
c'est impossible
qu'un homme des dieux
soit qualifié
pour quoi que ce soit
sans
qu'il ait
la responsabilité
de conserver
les mystères
de la piété
et quand la Bible
nous parle
des mystères
de la piété
c'est la doctrine
c'est l'enseignement
biblique
c'est de connaître
la vérité
correcte
nous sommes en train
de gérer
quoi ?
la maison des dieux
qui a la colonne
et l'appui
de la vérité
c'est impossible
de rendre
un bon service
en tant que diacre
sans avoir
la compréhension
de ce qui est
la colonne
et l'appui
de la vérité
ce qui est la vérité
ce qui est les mystères
et là Paul
il ne va pas
laisser Timothée
dans l'obscur
il va dire
au verset 14
au verset 16
et sans contredit
les mystères
de la piété
à grand
celui qui a été
manifesté en chair
justifié par l'esprit
vu des anges
prêchés aux gentils
cru dans les mondes
élevé dans la gloire
c'est-à-dire
il ne peut pas
régner
l'incarnation
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
manifesté en chair
ok ?
il ne peut pas
régner
les miracles
surnaturels
que le Christ a opéré
il a été justifié
par l'esprit
par les miracles
qu'il a opérés
mais aussi
par sa résurrection
il a été contemplé
des anges
donc quand on lit
les récits des Lucs
sur la naissance de Christ
etc.
et le fait
qu'il a été vu des anges
dans sa résurrection aussi
et dans la gloire aussi
aucun élément
surnaturel des écritures
un diacre
ne peut douter
ça ne peut pas
être difficile
pour lui
d'avoir des faiblesses
au niveau doctrinal
des faiblesses
qui sont
les plus grands
challenges
pour la génération
voilà
il dit
il a été manifesté
en chair
justifié de l'esprit
vu des anges
prêchés aux gentils
c'est-à-dire
cette foi
qui avait venu
à travers les juifs
est pour toutes les nations
crue dans les mondes
et élevée dans la gloire
glorification
résurrection
incarnation
et l'œuvre
d'expiation
de Saint Jésus Christ
et donc c'est important
de le rappeler
en fait
ici
c'est une présentation
très condensée
de quelques
principales vérités
qui concernent
les peuples des dieux
c'est clair
qu'un diacre
ne doit pas avoir
la connaissance
aussi technique
qu'elle des anciens
aussi profonde
aussi large
mais c'est quelqu'un
qui a
un odeur
comme
les chiens des gardes
il peut
ne pas avoir
la capacité
de tout formuler
comme un grand théologien
mais pour plus
qu'il n'ait pas
la capacité
de discuter
trop longtemps
avec un évolutionniste
il sait reconnaître
que c'est dangereux
qu'il faut éviter
que je dois préserver
les peuples des dieux
de cette personne
de ses influences
je dois peut-être
signaler les pasteurs
de certaines interactions
et conversations
et donc c'est très important
de remarquer
que parfois
des personnes
qui ont
un esprit
très simple
qui n'ont pas
un niveau d'éducation
très développé
ils ont plus
d'intégrité
doctrinale
que des personnes
qui peuvent être
très éduquées
et la réalité
c'est qu'ici
ces personnes
elles ont
une capacité
une qualification
divine
de savoir
apprendre
à chérir
la parole de Dieu
les enseignements
de la parole de Dieu
sont normalement
les plus assidus
les plus intéressés
dans les enseignements
et on voit
qu'ils sont
les plus vite
à pratiquer
à se laisser gouverner
par les écritures
la foi simplifiée
comme l'audi
disait
la plus grande expression
des fois
c'est lorsque
les hommes
et les femmes
sont dans les contentements
avec ce que la Bible
a révélé
et arrêtent
de poser des questions
c'est pas pour négliger
toutes les questions
qui enrichissent la foi
mais il y a certaines choses
qui deviennent
un mystère pour nous
et il faut qu'on sache dire
là je sais pas la réponse
mais je suis satisfait
avec ce que la Bible dit
si elle dit
que l'homme doit faire ceci
j'essaierai un homme
qui fait ceci
si elle dit
que la femme
ne peut pas faire cela
j'essaierai une femme
qui ne veut pas faire cela
et ces personnes là
sont les qualifiées
pour être diapes
qui sont jamais
en train de défier
l'enseignement biblique
mais qui veulent préserver
il les préserve
si nécessaire
par l'intellect
la compréhension
la connaissance
il les préserve
par la manière
dont ils pratiquent
l'évangile
et par les ailes
et par les discernements
qu'ils auront
d'identifier
les dangers
mais ce sont des personnes
qui vivent la foi
avec une conscience pure
pourquoi ?
car si avant
on a parlé
juste avant
du danger
du gant sordide
et Paul a lié
juste ensuite
de conserver
les mystères
de la piété
ou de la foi
c'est pour dire
je vais
agir
avec intégrité
car je ne peux pas
régner l'évangile
que je prêche
en prenant
l'avantage
sur cette position
donc c'est lié
à la manière
dont on vit
et c'est juste avant
les remarques
qui seront faites
envers la pureté
la préservation
de l'immoralité sexuelle
etc
et donc ils préservent
dans les deux sens
donc c'est important
de considérer
ces modèles
je me rappelle très bien
un frère
qui est déjà parti
à la gloire
mais qui était
l'un des frères
les plus pauvres
et les plus simples
de ma communauté
mais qui a toujours
marqué ma vie
à cause de la simplicité
et la profondeur
dont il vivait sa foi
il était comme un ange
entre nous
et servait le Seigneur
avec toute la joie
et une vie
d'intégrité incroyable
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
c'est une phase biblique
et donc il faut
qu'il soit capable
car il aura aussi
des occasions
où il doit
expliquer l'évangile
il aura parfois
plus d'occasion
d'évangéliser
que les pasteurs eux-mêmes
que les anciens eux-mêmes
et donc il faut
qu'il soit capable
d'expliquer l'évangile
de manière cohérente
il faut qu'il soit capable
de connaître
aussi tant la Bible
dans sa simplicité
qu'il puisse appliquer
les principes bibliques
pour gérer
une occasion
qui est là
devant lui
c'est très important
et donc
ensuite
un autre
un autre critère
relationnel
c'est
il doit être
mis à l'épreuve
c'est-à-dire
il doit être
irréprochable
dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions
il doit être
irréprochable
dans son service
donc lisons
les versets 10
qu'on les éprouve d'abord
et qu'ils exercent
ensuite leur ministère
si ils sont
sans réproche
donc c'est très intéressant
donc vu
que les enjeux
sont tellement importants
comme les destins éternels
des âmes
c'est la réputation
de l'évangile
préserver la foi
car
un diacre
disqualifié
immoral
il va être
une bombe atomique
au sein d'une église
il peut détruire
à cause d'un scandale
qu'il puisse commettre
en ayant
la vulnérabilité
de la confiance
des membres
en ayant accès
par exemple
à l'hospitalité
en ayant accès
à l'argent de l'église
ces scandales-là
peuvent
porter une grande
grande déception
au sein de l'église
et en dehors de l'église
voilà pourquoi
l'église ne doit être
jamais vite
à valider
pour plus que les personnes
manifestent
de manière externe
et pratiquent
dans leur service
une assiduité incroyable
il faut donner
du temps
et il faut confier
légèrement
et progressivement
des responsabilités
pour voir
cette prédisposition
de cette personne
à servir
ils doivent être testés
et trouvés fidèles
dans les services
ils doivent d'abord
être testés
et s'ils sont
irréprochables
ils sont confirmés
donc avant
qu'un homme
ne soit
officiellement
non médiacre
il doit prouver
sa fidélité
au Seigneur
comme Joseph
a dû prouver
sa fidélité
pour gérer
l'argent
des pharaons
il doit être
prédisposé
à souffrir
et garder
son intégrité
à faire
les travaux
les plus simples
on a été appelé
à suivre
un Seigneur
qui n'a pas eu
de problème
à faire le travail
d'un esclave
et nettoyer
les pieds
de ses disciples
et d'ailleurs
un ancien
qui n'est jamais
prédisposé
à faire ce type
de service
il est disqualifié
aussi pour être
un ancien
il n'est pas là
pour s'excuser
des travaux difficiles
il est là
pour faire
quelque part
l'un des travaux
les plus humiliants
selon la conception
biblique
les plus difficiles
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que même en faisant
son travail
il n'est jamais
complètement protégé
des devoirs
participer
aux travaux
les plus simples
si Dieu lui donne
l'opportunité
et donc c'est très important
nous sommes là
en train de considérer
qu'un service
fiable
et fidèle
doit se démontrer
avant qu'il soit
confirmé
c'est intéressant
car ces choses
et surtout
les plus difficiles
à la tâche
les plus amples
les plus grandes
est l'opportunité
de tester
son caractère
de qualifier
car si notre caractère
doit être
le plus proche
du Christ possible
les caractères
de cette personne
doivent être
les plus prédisposés
à servir
avec excellence
emblément
les tâches
les plus simples
qu'on puisse voir
et donc là
on voit
c'est une occasion
de tester
ce qu'on a appelé
la dignité
car la gloire
du Christ
elle a été
possiblement affichée
les plus
au moins aux yeux
des dieux
lorsqu'il a été
les plus disposé
à s'humilier
quand il était
les plus proches
de la croix
quand il a pris
nos péchés
sur lui
c'est là
où les anges
ont éclaté
en louange
c'est là
où Dieu
a dit
voici mon fils
aimé
bien aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
et nous devrions
chérir les personnes
qui nous servent
de manière humble
de la même manière
donc cette dignité
s'expose par là
on voit la symétrie
de sa vie
car il peut avoir
des capacités
très excellentes
très cultivées
des diplômes
des degrés
qui peuvent aider
l'église énormément
mais s'il n'est pas
disposé
à nettoyer
les toilettes
il y a une incohérence
il faut avoir
cette symétrie
c'est très intéressant
c'est cette prédisposition
à servir
comme les Christ
notre roi serviteur
donc il doit
l'église doit
quelque part
établir les schémas
les plus durs
pour quelqu'un
qui veut être
un candidat
au diakona
c'est intéressant
là par exemple
à mon église
on avait l'habitude
tout ce qui était
candidat même ancien
on devrait faire
quelques tâches
qui étaient
d'entre les plus simples
de la communauté
et c'est comme
quelqu'un
en théologie
a déjà dit
si quelqu'un
s'est appelé au ministère
mettez les schémas
les plus durs pour lui
car s'il persévère
ça confirme
qu'il a été appelé
et quelque part
les diakres
c'est aussi la même chose
donc bien sûr
avec la proportion nécessaire
selon les temps nécessaires
en accord avec les dons
mais c'est intéressant
il faut donner des responsabilités
pour qu'on puisse avoir
l'occasion
de tester la fidélité
ceux qui sont fidèles
dans les peu
ce sont ceux qui sont qualifiés
pour être fidèles
dans beaucoup
et par l'inverse
et donc
c'est par là
qu'on va examiner
leur constance
leur assiduité
comment ils vont régler
par exemple
si jamais
ils ont des impératifs
où ils ne peuvent plus apparaître
comment ils vont faire
en fait
pour que la tâche
soit quand même exécutée
comment ils vont prendre
cette responsabilité
au lieu de passer
les problèmes à un autre
mais comment ils vont régler
les problèmes eux-mêmes
et là en fait
même les non-chrétiens
ont la capacité
d'avoir
ces niveaux de responsabilité
et nous
on devrait avoir
ces mêmes
ces mêmes types
de prédispositions
si on considère
les services
à l'église
constance
assiduité
mentalité
persévérance
résilience
et excellence
c'est très important
troisième
qualification
relationnelle
c'est qu'il doit être
moralement
irréprochable
non seulement
dans les services
mais irréprochable
moralement
car
tous les contextes
nous parlent
des critères
des dignités
spirituelles
et morales
et ici
cette épreuve
qu'ils soient
éprouvés d'abord
et qu'ils exercent
ensuite leur ministère
et les textes
dans l'original
est très intéressant
il dit
si
ils sont en train
de se développer
dans l'exercice
de leur ministère
dans un exercice
irréprochable
c'est-à-dire
tant qu'ils soient
ils soient irréprochables
nous voyons
des signes
de qualification
ok
même s'il y a
on va dire
de la marge
pour un développement
c'est important
de reconnaître
qu'il y a
la possibilité
de grandir
sauf que
même si
on n'est pas encore
un modèle
tel qu'on aimerait être
on n'est pas non plus
en train de tomber
dans un péché
qui puisse disqualifier
et ça c'est très important
car s'il y a
cette conception
dans la Bible
des qualifications
ou des disqualifications
pour les ministères
nous ne pouvons pas
jouer avec ça
MacArthur
il doit dire ça
clairement
l'une des raisons
les plus tragiques
pour les paramètres
de sainteté à l'église
dans nos jours
c'est
des traités
comme négociables
des choses
qui Dieu ne nous a
jamais permis
des traités
comme négociables
donc quel est
le standard
pour quelqu'un
qui doit occuper
la position des diacres
comme par exemple
il dit ici
mari d'une seule femme
donc c'est pas
les cas
d'une personne
qui a pu être
divorcée
avant sa conversion
ou par des raisons
légitimes
mais c'est une personne
qui n'a eu pas
des causes
pour se retrouver
dans cette condition
où elle a été
fautive
et dans tous
les autres éléments
qu'il soit fidèle
dans la gestion
des finances
d'argent
qu'il n'ait jamais
pratiqué
une espèce
des gants sordides
si cette personne
n'a jamais été
disqualifiée
par la déviation
d'argent
ou par l'adultère
ou l'immoralité
sexuelle
cette personne
est qualifiée
et reste qualifiée
pour les diaconas
tant qu'elle préserve
son intégrité
mais à partir du moment
où elle disqualifie
pourquoi Paul
il parle dans ses langues
c'est lui qui a
le plus défendu
la non-perte de salut
et donc quand il dit
qu'il frappe son corps
et les réduit
à la servitude
pour qu'un ayant
prêché à d'autres
il ne soit pas disqualifié
c'est évident
pour les commentaristes
qu'il est en train
de parler
de son ministère
et il devrait s'efforcer
pour se préserver
de la tentation
à supporter
à réduire à néant
les inclinations
et les appels
de la chair
et donc c'est très important
de considérer
la possibilité
d'être disqualifiée
une personne disqualifiée
elle ne perd pas son salut
elle peut rester
un membre de l'église
elle doit recevoir
l'amour
les pardons
la motivation
pour se sanctifier
mais elle ne peut pas
occuper une position
dont la Bible nous dit
voici les pré-réquisitions
pour occuper cette place
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
qu'une église
comme disait
Esporgeon
ne dépasse jamais
les poupitres
et dans ma connaissance
par expérience personnelle
la plupart d'églises
qui étaient très vite
à pardonner
et restablir
sur un poupitre
une personne
qui a tombé
dans un péché
des disqualifications
ça s'est reproduit
très vite
envers la communauté
ce sont les églises
qui finissent
par tomber
dans les mêmes erreurs
de ces pasteurs
et donc il faut
qu'on fasse attention
à cet égard
donc il faut
qu'il soit
irréprochable
les termes
dans l'original
c'est sans tâche
c'est cette notion
d'être innocent
qui n'est pas la perfection
dans notre cas
mais qui évoque
la pureté
et la propriété
dont on doit chercher
pour être utilisé par Dieu
donc il y a cet aspect
pour la pureté sexuelle
qui est évident
surtout par la mention
d'être mari
d'une seule femme
et on va considérer
la dernière
la dernière qualification
qui est
une vie
des familles
fidèles
et exemplaires
c'est très important
et on va conclure
avec ce point
c'est
lorsqu'il nous lisons
et ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps
dans les passages
beaucoup d'espace
dans ces passages
il dit
les diacres
doivent être mari
d'une seule femme
et diriger bien
leurs enfants
et leur propre maison
donc c'est intéressant
nous sommes en train
de parler
de la maison des dieux
c'est le même passage
nous ne pouvons jamais oublier
et c'est impossible
d'être qualifié
pour prendre soin
de la maison des dieux
si nous ne sommes pas
en train d'exercer
nos rôles
particuliers
dans notre propre maison
de manière responsable
donc
ici le texte
va évoquer
que dans ces contextes
familiales
et des maisons
il y a quelque chose
qui se rapporte
à la femme
à l'épouse
il y a quelque chose
qui se rapporte
aux enfants
il y a quelque chose
qui se rapporte
à la gestion
de la maison
et ces trois qualifications
sont très importantes
de manière très pratique
pour l'exercice
des fonctions
de diacre
au sein de l'église
l'église
est l'épouse
du Christ
l'église
est la maison
des dieux
et nous sommes en train
d'exercer
une fonction
des relations
avec les enfants
des dieux
et donc c'est très important
car
les termes
qui nous disent
diriger
ça peut parler
gouverner aussi
ou contrôler
ou être au contrôle
et c'est important
de distinguer
de dominer
exploiter
ou porter
un contrôle absolu
sur les personnes
qui composent
notre famille
ou la maison
c'est pas
un folle
contrôlateur
c'est pas
quelqu'un
qui a réussi
à faire
qu'il soit épouse
l'obéisse
de manière aveugle
et qu'elle se porte
et qu'elle s'habille
exactement
de la manière
dont il exige
ou que ses enfants
comme des robots
l'effacent
des mêmes
ou que sa maison
en fait
c'est que sa volonté
qui est prise
en considération
respectée
et toutes les choses
dans les détails
se passent dans la maison
exactement
comme je veux
c'est pas
cet indice là
que la Bible
est en train
de nous pointer
c'est quelqu'un
qui doit diriger
et avoir
cette relation
envers
son épouse
ses enfants
et sa maison
avec les rôles
des leadership
des dirigeants
qu'il ne soit pas
négligent
envers
les aspects
charnels
qui peuvent mener
à un manque
de contrôle
biblique
dans la maison
chez les enfants
et même
chez l'épouse
qu'elle ne se porte
pas complètement
selon son envie
envers
les dépenses
superflues
triviales
etc.
qu'elle ne soit pas
complètement
soumise
etc.
que les enfants
non plus
ne soient
complètement
désordonnés
comme dans la génération
qui deviennent
otages
que les parents
deviennent
otages
des enfants
sans pouvoir
les corriger
les reprocher
et donc
bien sûr
qui ne sont pas
ni les tâches
l'extrême
de la suppression
d'autres personnalités
ni par
un libertinage
irresponsable
c'est de diriger
tel que la Bible
présente
avec l'équilibre
biblique
donc c'est
d'exercer
leurs tâches
de manière
exemplaire
pas
parfaite
mais exemplaire
quelle est ma tâche
en tant que mari
de cette maison
qu'est-ce que je dois faire
quelle est ma tâche
en tant que père
de ces enfants
qu'est-ce que je dois faire
quelle est ma tâche
en tant que chef
de ma maison
comment je participe
à la direction
des choses
tout en respectant
les autres personnes
afin de les amener
à leur épanouissement
l'épanouissement
de chaque individu
de la maison
et surtout envers
la spiritualité
de cette maison
pour la gloire de Dieu
c'est quelque part
l'évidence suprême
de la spiritualité
ni tous seront appelés
à diacres
à anciens
mais nous ne pouvons pas
confondre
place d'évidence
dans l'église
à synonyme
de spiritualité
bien sûr
que ces offices
demandent
que des personnes
véritablement qualifiées
soient
ou aient une spiritualité
au-dessus de la moyenne
par contre
c'est possible
que nous ayons
d'entre les membres
des personnes
beaucoup plus spirituelles
ou remplies de Saint-Esprit
qui sont les anciens
et les diacres
et c'est intéressant
car lorsqu'il habille
il va mettre l'emphase
l'apôtre Paul
quand il va parler
d'être rempli de Saint-Esprit
il va parler
de la relation maritale
et la relation père-enfant
et la relation au travail
il ne va pas parler
directement
de l'office de diacre
ou des anciens
et nous ne pouvons pas
faire cette confusion
sinon on peut être tenté
d'occuper des places
qui ne sont pas pour nous
parce que Dieu chérit
surtout
notre spiritualité
et un grand nombre
des personnes
comme Matthieu VII nous dit
qui occupent la chair
ou les diaconats
et qui se rendent
à trouver l'enfer
et c'est très important
de considérer
pas la capacité
de cet homme
de prêcher la parole
mais comme j'ai eu
cette expérience
par la grâce des dieux
avec Paul Hachère
quand on est allé
les visiter
pour qu'il examine
notre possibilité
d'être connecté
à la trame
il était dans un moment
très difficile
proche d'un burn out
et à ce moment-là
on était dans une conversation
et des fois
il dormait
et tout
et j'ai posé la question
Paul je voulais vraiment
profiter de cette situation
est-ce qu'il y a encore
des questions
que je dois vous poser
il a dit
des missionnaires
avec une bonne théologie
je connais beaucoup
si je t'appelais ici
avec ta famille
c'était pour voir
comment tu traites
ton épouse
et tes enfants
et c'est là
en fait
on doit chercher
la qualification
c'est intéressant
Andy Hamilton
il a dit le suivant
la première chose
qui se rapporte
à notre épouse
l'essentiel
c'est qu'un diacre
doit être totalement
consacré et dévoué
à son épouse
ok
mari d'une seule femme
les femmes de l'église
ne seront pas
une tentation pour lui
tant qu'il soit
critérieux
pour avoir légitimement
cette appréciation
envers son épouse
traiter son épouse
de cette manière
car même
les critères
pour se rapporter
aux femmes de l'église
sont une expression
de combien il chérit
son épouse
des limites
des distances
c'est important
donc c'est intéressant
ce qu'il dit
Andy Hamilton
c'est surtout
ses interactions
avec son épouse
qui vont démontrer
son spiritualité
et il dit
ton épouse
n'est pas ta concubine
pour te fournir
de manière égoïste
ton plaisir sexuel
elle n'est pas
ta femme de ménage
pour garder la maison
toujours en ordre
elle n'est pas ta cuisinière
pour te pourvoir
de la nourriture
tous les temps
elle n'est pas non plus
ta nounou
pour prendre soin
de tes enfants
elle est ton épouse
elle est ton aide
ta co-servante
elle est
celle
qui tu dois traiter
comme Christ
traite l'église
travailler pour son
épanouissement spirituel
prendre en considération
que si Dieu
l'a placé dans ma vie
comme mon aide
comme mon auxilia
je prends en considération
son avis
sa participation
dans les décisions
je vais la décharger
je vais l'aider aussi
à nettoyer
la maison
les vaisselles
à préparer
la nourriture
ça c'est une expression
de spiritualité
c'est très important
de considérer
cette réalité
cela va se manifester
comment je prends
en considération
son aide
comment Christ
l'aime
et cela va guider
la manière
dont je vais l'aimer
ça va prendre en considération
ma responsabilité
aussi envers les enfants
c'est aux parents
et premièrement
aux pères
de corriger
d'instruire
d'entraîner
et la femme
elle aide
ce n'est pas
les bons policiers
les mauvais policiers
à la maison
en laissant la femme
faire toujours
le travail
le plus dur
donc si je ne dignifie pas
mon épouse
comme il faut
comment je peux
dignifier
l'épouse du Christ
qui est l'église
une question
assez posée
par rapport aux enfants
quelle est ma tâche
en tant que père
quelles sont mes responsabilités
je ne peux pas
les convertir
à force
mais je dois
exercer mon rôle
les conduire
l'évangéliser
superviser
ce qu'ils apprennent
à l'école
participer
les préparer
anticiper
les défis
qu'ils auront
je ne peux pas
consacrer
plus de mon temps
aux troupeaux
à l'église
ou à quoi que ce soit
si je n'ai pas
cette priorité
établie
claire
dans ma tête
si je ne suis pas
entraîné
dans la protection
et dans l'instruction
de mes enfants
envers l'évangile
c'est très important
de considérer
quelles sont
mes tâches
envers mes enfants
de manière très claire
par les principes bibliques
pas par apparence
pas par
une crainte des hommes
mais par un amour
sans perdre le cœur
pourquoi à la fin
donc là
ça s'applique aussi
à la maison
on n'a pas de temps
pour rentrer
dans tous les détails
pour la maison
mais je dois participer
dans les affaires de la maison
je dois avoir
une notion
d'entendance
d'organisation
pour pouvoir aussi
aider la communauté
mais la réalité
c'est que
nous ne sommes pas
en train de chercher
une perfection
dans l'apparence
je ne cherche pas
que mon épouse
fasse semblant devant vous
que je suis les maris parfaits
je ne pouvais pas
transmettre sur mon épouse
des attentes
que la communauté
parfois peut avoir
envers la femme d'un pasteur
certaines femmes
ne peuvent que gérer
de nourrir
comme il a dit
nos petits animaux
qui sont nos enfants
dans leur rébellion
et qui sont très fatigués
avec ça
ni toutes les femmes
des pasteurs
ont été appelées
à exercer
les mêmes fonctions
dans les corps
certaines sont plus douées
pour certaines choses
d'autres pour d'autres
mais elle est mon auxiliaire
elle est mon épouse
et la réalité
c'est que quand on considère
la manière dont
ma relation avec elle
est authentique
est légitime
et ma relation
avec mes enfants
je ne peux pas élever
les diacres ne peuvent pas
élever leurs enfants
afin de plaire
par l'apparence
de la communauté
de les contrôler
de se faire porter
pour l'apparence
pour plaire les personnes
je dois avoir
quelques points
critérieux
pour exercer
mes tâches
les moments
de dévotion
l'enseignement
l'instruction
la correction
mais je vais chercher
surtout
à développer
leur évangélisation
par amour
par la joie
par passer des temps
de qualité ensemble
et ce sont les priorités
que tous doivent avoir
et c'est la même chose
qu'on va exercer
à l'église
je suis rentré
dans la Sacré-Cœur
pour visiter
il y avait un homme
qui semblait
exercer la fonction
d'un diacre
son ministère
était de faire
avec une expression
d'amour rare
ça se voyait
qu'il avait
un zèle énorme
mais
les visages
des violences
d'agressivité
fait qu'on perd
tout de suite
les cœurs des personnes
donc on a un zèle
et on aimerait
qu'on crée des habitudes
dans la communauté
que les enfants
ne les mangent pas
peut-être dans la salle
moi je ne m'oppose pas
ça forcément
mais peut-être
qu'on pourrait avoir
cet aspect
plutôt solennel
à la notion
du sanctuaire
etc
sauf que s'il arrive
un enfant
qui n'a pas fait
beaucoup d'attention
ou un visiteur
qui arrive
avec son verre
des cafés
pendant les cultes
je dois
et c'est que
si j'ai l'expérience
authentique
d'amour
à la maison
où je ne veux pas
perdre le cœur
de mon enfant
et je vais savoir
quelles sont les batailles
que je dois lutter
contre lui
et quelles sont
les batailles
que je puisse
tolérer
chez lui
et la même chose
s'appliquera
avec équilibre
dans la maison
des dieux
les diac
n'est pas préoccupé
qu'il soit
en service honoré
qu'il soit respecté
peut-être
parfois
on manquera
de respect
envers nous
mais notre préoccupation
c'est de gagner
leurs âmes
leur cœur
vous comprenez
et ce sont des choses
que nous n'apprenons
qu'à la maison
pas forcément
comme parents
mais même
comme enfants
et ce sont des choses
qu'on apprend
à la maison
et donc
c'est pour ça
en fait
que Dieu
va juger
les pères
qui nous sommes
ou les mères
selon
combien on a exercé
nos tâches
et pas forcément
par rapport aux fruits
car c'est à Dieu
d'honorer à son temps
leur salut
leur conversion
mais moi
je dois être évalué
vous vous devez être évalué
vous devez vous évaluer
et les diac
doivent être évalués
par rapport à la manière
dont ils gèrent
leur maison
est-ce qu'ils sont là
au rendez-vous
pour aimer
pour soigner
pour protéger
pour instruire
pour corriger
avec équilibre
avec amour
comme Christ
à chercher
à aimer son église
un Christ
qui n'a pas tout simplement
pourvu aux besoins
mais qui a été généreux
envers son épouse
et qui a été préoccupé
avec son embellissement
et c'est l'objectif
des diacres
au sein de l'église
Amen
voilà les qualifications
je sais que j'ai dépassé
un peu le temps
mais il fallait que je
conclue aujourd'hui